[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute netz
barbara halt guten abend und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
samstag die vom sport hat norbert
lehmann noch vor mir und das sind die
themen von heute
countdown für den krisengipfel der g7
auf schloss elmau suchen die spitzen
führende industriestaaten nach lösungen
neue doppelspitze für die linke janine
wissler und martin schilde waren sollen
die partei aus der krise führen und
große gewinner beim deutschen filmpreis
das drama lieber thomas bekommt neun
lolas unter anderem für den besten
spielfilm
der kanzler als gastgeber ist schon da
der us-präsident als mächtigster gast im
anflug zu diesem möglicherweise
wichtigsten g7 gipfel überhaupt dort
gilt es auch die einheit gegen
kriegstreiber russland weiter zu
schmieden der russische präsident ist
seit der annexion der krim vor acht
jahren vom gipfel kreis ausgeschlossen
die g7 das sind japan kanada die usa
großbritannien frankreich italien und
deutschland zusammen kommen sie auf
knapp ein drittel der globalen
wirtschaftsleistung
die staats und regierungschefs plus die
eu-spitze treffen sich im landkreis
garmisch-partenkirchen auf schloss elmau
rund um das luxus ressort gibt es eine
sicherheitszone 16 kilometer absperrung
insgesamt 18.000 polizistinnen und
polizisten
morgen geht es offiziell los andreas
küppers
es ist der erste internationale gipfel
den kanzler scholz als gastgeber
erklimmt der weiße fleck im dritten
fenster deutschland hat einen g 7 gipfel
zu organisieren der zum krisentreffen
geworden ist als kanzler kompakt wendet
sich scholz online antideutschen elmau
liegt in den tagen lage versetzen werden
wird dort sicher nicht aber wir können
wichtige entscheidungen treffen und
dinge vorbereiten die für uns alle
nützlich sind wenn wir geschlossen
handeln und entschlossen sind darum
geht's in ihrem schloss in den bergen
wird fast jedes gespräch der großen 7
von einem acht bestimmt putins krieg
gegen die ukraine und die dadurch
eskalierende welthunger krise drängen
den kampf gegen den klimawandel in den
hintergrund
wie zum beweis veröffentlichte das
russische militär heute diese bilder und
meldet die ukraine beschuss auf alle
landesteile russland demonstriert
militärische und politische stärke
präsident putin sagt präsident
lukaschenko die lieferung
atomwaffenfähige raketen zu
überraschender g2 gipfel in st
petersburg
die g7 wollen in ellmau noch einmal die
welt aufrütteln vor allem asien und
afrika
so viele länder sagen das ist ein
europäischer krieg der wirtschaftliche
probleme verursacht die wir wirklich
nicht gebrauchen können dadurch wächst
der druck auf die menschen in der
ukraine auch einen schlechten frieden zu
akzeptieren
in diesen minuten sind alle sieben auf
dem weg nach bayern morgen am ersten tag
wollen sie unter sich sein am montag
werden die gäste erwartet aus südamerika
asien und afrika
welche bedeutung hat diese gipfel theo
koll kritiker sagen die besetzung sei
längst nicht mehr zeitgemäß
ja das stimmt die kritik ist absolut auf
den punkt denn die g7 vertreten zwar 30
prozent der welt wirtschaftskraft aber
nur noch zehn prozent der
weltbevölkerung es ist ein klub der
wohlhabenden der immer weniger menschen
vertritt aber es gilt problem erkannt
der kanzler hat fünf große länder unter
anderem indien und indonesien dazu
geladen sie sollen hier in dieser jahr
fast unwirklich eine idylle von schloss
elmau umworben werden denn viele haben
sich im systemwettbewerb zwischen
einerseits russland und china und
beispielsweise den g7 andererseits nicht
festgelegt es ist also auch ein werben
um werte die länder die russlands
angriffskrieg nicht verurteilt haben
vertreten immerhin fast die hälfte der
weltbevölkerung
ich glaube ein teil der kritik greift
auch zu kurz in diesen multi
krisenzeiten ernährung energie klima ist
jede funktionierende abstimmung ein
gewinn aber ein bescheidener rahmen wäre
durchaus auch ein gewinn theo koll live
aus ellmau dankeschön
im 100 kilometer entfernten münchen
hatten für heute 15
globalisierungskritische verbände zum
protest gegen den gipfel aufgerufen
motto gerecht geht anders
allerdings kamen sehr viel weniger
menschen als erwartet
alexander pohl
es ist nur eine von vielen parolen an
diesem tag in münchen doch sie ertönen
leiser als erwartet mit 20.000
teilnehmern hatten die veranstalter
gerechnet am ende kamen zwischen vier
und sechs tausend ganz viele menschen
sind verunsichert ob man jetzt gerade
für klimagerechtigkeit für soziale
gerechtigkeit gegen die die sich immer
draußen auf die straße gehen soll oder
ob man sie nicht sogar unterstützen muss
bei der frage der konfrontation in der
ukraine manche aber sind genau deswegen
hier menschen die aufrüstung aus
tiefstem herzen ablehnen und trotzdem
mehr waffen für die ukraine fordern wir
hoffen dass diese
gestoppt aufgehalten wird und dafür
denken wir braucht es schwerere waffen
auf der kundgebung ein breites spektrum
an umweltschützern
globalisierungsgegnern und
kapitalismuskritikern sie eint die
skepsis gegen den g 7 gipfel der morgen
auf schloss elmau beginnt da geht es den
einen um mehr gerechtigkeit
ich würde mir wünschen dass solche
treffen auch staaten einbeziehen die im
momentan nicht repräsentiert sind die
globalen süden kommen vielen bereitet
die klimakrise sorgen und eine politik
die darauf nicht schnell genug reagieren
wir wollen
dass das was schon beschlossen
im pariser abkommen wenn zum beispiel
einfach mal umgesetzt wird der großteil
der demonstration verlief friedlich nur
am rande kam es zu auseinandersetzungen
mit der polizei
spannende und wegweisende gipfeltage in
oberbayern über die aktuellen
entwicklungen halten wir sie in unserer
zdf heute app unter anderem mit einem
live blog immer auf dem laufenden
die ukraine ist ja seit vorgestern
eu-beitrittskandidat nun erklärte
präsident sie lenski er wolle auch
georgien helfen näher an die europäische
union zu rücken in georgien
demonstrierten gestern abend
zehntausende für einen eu beitritt ihres
landes sie werfen ihre regierung vor
sich nicht ausreichend für den
kandidatenstatus eingesetzt zu haben
für unruhe sorgen gefälschte videoanrufe
eines vermeintlichen witali klitschkos
bei europäischen bürgermeistern auch in
berlin bei franziska giffey rief ein
mann an der genauso aussah und sprach
wie der kia für bürgermeister dann aber
wegen seltsamer fragen auffiel es war
offenbar eine sorgfältig manipulierte
video schalte ein sogenanntes die fake
wer dahintersteckt ist offen
zum parteitag der linken der bekommt
janine wissler eine zweite chance die
hessen wurde als vorsitzende
wiedergewählt
und das obwohl die 41-jährige umstritten
war nach etlichen wahlniederlagen und
internen grabenkämpfen neu im führungs
duo der eu abgeordnete martin
schirdewahn aus erfurt berichtet karl
hinterleitner
es kommt darauf an sie zu verändern
damit meinte karl marx einmal die ganze
welt die heutige linke meint die eigene
partei zu 15 jahre linke kam denn von
gründungsmitglied gysi auch eine
gratulation der besonderen art zu
unserem fünfzehnten geburtstag
faellt mir ich muss es sagen kein
rechter glückwunsch 1 da wir uns in
einer existenziellen krise befinden das
müssen wir alle begreifen vieles ist
unklar in der linken zb die haltung zum
ukraine krieg am mittag an entscheidende
moment für janine wissler die zwei
waffenlieferungen ablehnt aber russland
klar als schuldigen benennen dagegen gab
es in mehreren anträgen widerstand sie
brauchen eine verurteilung des
russischen krieges gegen die ukraine
ohne wenn und aber
bisher setzt sich damit durch und
gewinnt die wahl zur vorsitzenden mit
57,5 prozent holt sie aber fast 30
prozent weniger als beim letzten mal co-
vorsitzender ihr wunschkandidat martin
schade war mit 61 prozent auch nicht
überragend trotz des jubels das spitzen
nur wird damit von beinahe der hälfte
der partei nicht unterstützt martin
schirdewahn gibt sich trotzdem
optimistisch
ich glaube das signal ist eindeutig wir
haben verstanden als linke wir sind
wieder da als linke und das ist auch das
signal dass dieser parteitag nach außen
sendet an die bürgerinnen und bürger
das signal wirklich ankommt bleibt
fraglich die befürchtete schlammschlacht
blieb in erfurt zwar aus die linke aber
ist weiter angeschlagen
ralf schumacher in erfurt kann diese
neue spitze die partei aus der krise
führen
saadi wissler hat hier zumindest in
erfurt leidenschaftlich gekämpft um ihr
politisches überleben und das ihrer
partei sie hat eingegriffen in die
heikle ukraine debatten ist damit hohes
risiko gegangen in der traditionell
russlandfreundlichen linken die die nato
weiterhin abschaffen will whistler
bekommt mit dem europa politiker martin
gewann ihren wunschkandidaten als
co-chef ein mann vom reformflügel ein
stratege denn auch bundespolitisch noch
wenig bekannt diese neue doppelspitze
will die linke wieder beleben als
eine opposition zur ampel der parteitag
hat diesen neuanfang bejubelt sich
selbst mut gemacht geschlossenheit
gezeigt wohl auch weil sarah wagenknecht
die sich gegen wisla ausgesprochen hatte
hier krankheitsbedingt fehlte ob dieses
neue duo tatsächlich das neue
machtzentrum der linken wird dass die
grabenkämpfe beendet die sexismus
debatte gründlich aufarbeitet und in
zentralen fragen künftig den politischen
kurs der partei prägt das ist völlig
offen aber entscheidend für die zukunft
der linken danke für diese einschätzung
aus erfurt ralf schumacher war dass
sie haben sich einiges vorgenommen cdu
und grüne in nordrhein westfalen das
land soll zum modell für europa werden
klimaschutz und industrie vereinen heute
stimmten landesparteitage der künftigen
partner dem koalitionsvertrag zu am
dienstag steht die wiederwahl von
ministerpräsident wüst im landtag an nrw
grünenchefin neubauer soll
superministerin für wirtschaft klima und
energie werden doch der vater berichtet
hendrik wüst umjubelt in bonn er hat
seine cdu nrw zum wahlsieg geführt nun
wirbt er für den koalitionsvertrag mit
den grünen heute kann ich sagen das
fundament für eine erfolgreiche arbeit
für nordrhein westfalen auch in den
nächsten fünf jahren ist gelegt und wir
wollen nordrhein westfalen zu ersten
klimaneutralen
industrieregion europas machen die
zustimmung für den koalitionsvertrag
dann überwältigend bei 600 delegierten
gibt es gerade mal vier gegenstimmen die
cdu behält der kern ressort innere
sicherheit und bekommen verantwortung
für die schulpolitik also die punkte
innere sicherheit schule und bildung
aber auch in der zusammenklang von
wirtschaft und ökologie ich glaube da
passen die beiden koalitionspartner
wirklich gut zusammen jetzt
auch in bielefeld wird gejubelt
parteichefin mona neubauer hat den
grünen das beste nrw-ergebnis niemals
beschert aber schwarz grün stößt auf den
widerstand der grünen jugend
überzeugungsarbeit wir haben auch
erreicht dass bei der nächsten
landtagswahl alle die 16 sind an diesem
hochamt der demokratie teilhaben können
wahlrecht ab 16 1000 meter abstand mehr
für windräder trotz grüner herzens
projekte bleibt skepsis beim thema
braunkohle abbau und damit fällt dieser
koalitionsvertrag der klimabewegung an
essentiellen stellen in den rücken das
ist anders der vater oliver krischer
designierte nrw umweltminister er wirbt
aus der quarantäne für den
koalitionsvertrag am ende bekommt der
vertrag auch hier eine 85 prozent
mehrheit schwarz grüne nordrhein
westfalen steht
in norwegens hauptstadt oslo sind bei
einem angriff auf ein homosexuellen war
in der nacht zwei menschen getötet
worden mehr als 20 wurden verletzt
die polizei konnte den mutmaßlichen
täter festnehmen eine neue wege mit
iranischen wurzeln
die behörden vermuten einen
islamistischen hintergrund
norwegen setzte die höchste
terrorwarnstufe in kraft eine für heute
geplante pride parade wurde abgesagt
dennoch gingen viele auf die straße um
für die rechte quere menschen zu
demonstrieren
fataler massenansturm gestern auf den
grenzzaun der spanischen exklave melilla
in marokko inzwischen berichten medien
von mindestens 18 toten und 2000
flüchtlinge hatten versucht eu gebiet zu
erreichen
auch dutzende sicherheitskräfte seien
verletzt worden marokko war auf den
migranten vor gewalt eingesetzt zu haben
eine örtliche menschenrechtsorganisation
beschuldigt dagegen die
sicherheitskräfte migranten misshandelt
zu haben
jetzt nach berlin wenn sich 1700
filmschaffende in schale schmeißen dann
ist die lola nicht weit
die lola das ist die bedeutendste und am
höchsten dotierte auszeichnung der
deutschen filmbranche die gäste genossen
die kontakte und feierten vor allem ein
film als großen gewinner aus berlin
sebastian kowski
mit zwölf nominierungen galten sie die
macher des films lieber thomas als die
großen favoriten des abends und sie
wurden nicht enttäuscht
die lola in gold geht an
die produzentinnen fahren lieber thomas
die goldene lola für den besten
spielfilm gewann das porträt des
schriftstellers thomas brasch zerrissen
rebellisch unangepasst gespielt von
albrecht schuch der dafür als bester
hauptdarsteller geehrt wurde ich bin
sehr überwältigt kann sicher sagen ich
hätte gerne ein thomas brasch in den arm
genommen
tue das innerlich den preis für die
beste hauptdarstellerin bekam meltem
kaptan für ihre rolle im drama rabie
kurnaz gegen george double you busch die
wahre geschichte des
guantánamo-häftlings murat kurnaz und
den kampf seiner mutter für seine
freilassung
es ist mir wichtig weil das ist
tatsächlich bin ich in deutschland
geboren aufgewachsen deutsche filme
haben mich geprägt das ist ja meine
kultur ein abend ganz im zeichen des
deutschen films und ein deutliches
signal dass die branche auch trotz
pandemie weiterhin für starke filme made
in germany steht
und verstärken sport made in germany
stehen die finales in berlin norbert die
deutschen meisterschaften in 14
sportarten ja über die hälfte der 190
titel die sind schon vergeben besonders
spannend heute der triathlon sprint der
frauen ein packender zweikampf zwischen
annika koch und laura lindemann die
ihren dritten meistertitel holte die
potsdamerin ist nach 750 meter schwimmen
20 kilometer radfahren und fünf
kilometer laufen neun sekunden schneller
als annika koch lindemann ist damit
qualifiziert für die em in münchen im
august
torben johannesen und niklas schröder
gewinnen den titel im zweier ohne
steuermann gegen lauritz vollert und
julian guard team kollegen aus dem
deutschland-achter setzten sich
johannesen schröder im finale auf der
spree durch
sarah voss aus köln holt ihren zweiten
titel in berlin nach dem sieg im
mehrkampf gestern gewinnziel vor carina
schönmeier und lona hacker auch die
entscheidung am sprung und
jetzt schauen wir auf die leichtathletik
wettkämpfe da hat stabhochspringer
bekannter liter wäre den titel geholt
und mit fünf meter neunzig ein
ausrufezeichen an die internationale
konkurrenz außerhalb von berlin gesendet
um 9 cm verbesserte bog an der liga wäre
seine bisherige bestleistung
zugegeben viel luft war da nicht mehr
zwischen dem 23 jährigen unter
stabhochsprung latte aber mit diesen
fünf meter neunzig ist er derzeit
dritter der welt und medaillenkandidat
bei der kommenden wm
das gilt auch für diskuswerferin kristin
pudenz die ihren diskus auf 67 meter 10
schleuderte und damit 32 zentimeter
weiter als bislang in ihrer karriere ihr
vierter deutscher meistertitel
auf diesem weg ist auch sprinterin china
lückenkemper die ihr halbfinale über 100
meter locker gewann und mit einer zeit
von 11 29 souverän ins abendliche finale
zog
und china lückenkemper ist heute abend
zu gast bei uns im aktuellen sportstudio
um 23.30 und morgen dann die finale in
berlin live bei uns im zdf ab 10 uhr 15
zur schwimm-wm im budapester hat florian
wellbrock über die 1500 meter freistil
seinen titel nicht verteidigen können
weltmeister wurde italiener gregorio
premiere der von beginn an das rennen
anführte und souverän gewann einen
packenden kampf um platz zwei lieferten
sich wellbrock und bobby fink denn der
us-amerikaner 40
und du kannst mertens aus magdeburg
wurde führte das war's vom sport vielen
dank gesunder sport wo morgen die sonne
scheint und wo es gewittert sagt uns
gleich ist intelli marietta slomka
begrüßt sie um viertel nach elf im heute
journal wir sagen danke für ihr
interesse wir sagen tschüss und freuen
uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei sind
einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]
schon glaubte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter festgefahrene
wetterverhältnisse haben wir morgen und
auch in den nächsten tagen das liegt an
diesem hoch hier was sich kaum weg
bewegt ja auch die tiefste haben keine
chance die müssen nach norden ausweichen
mit dem jetstream der auch weit nach
norden zieht und dabei gelangt heiße
luft aus nordafrika bis richtung
skandinavien hoch der kommenden nacht
gibt es im osten noch einige schauer und
gewitter das lässt nach neue ziehen auf
und die beschränkten sich hauptsächlich
auf den westen deutschlands und die
temperaturen sinken auf 17 graz zum
beispiel nach nordosten hin dort ist es
am mildesten und elf grad zum beispiel
im vogtland sonst aber häufig im
südosten bei unter 15 grad morgen
tagesverlauf neue gewitter im südwesten
nach westen und bis zur ostsee und die
können durchaus auch starkregen bringen
sonst scheint häufig die sonne die
temperaturen dazu bis 33 grad heiss
häufig die werte um die 30 grad marke
etwas kühler ganz im westen bei 22 grad
hier oder montag erreicht uns eine neue
unwetterfront von westen her
temperaturen bis 35 grad ein schöner
abend